sakodo oreiller sous le bras c'est
l'heure malgré la pointe d'appréhension
il faut bien rentrer mais li 15 ans la
boule au ventre elle ne connaît pas
c'est bien ça avec juliette
avant de rejoindre sa chambre passage
par la case vestiaire sportif cette
année mais lee entrent en seconde
section ski de fond à une trentaine de
minutes de chez elles l'internât du
lycée c'est pour elle une tranquillité
en plus de nos cours normaux ont fait
des entraînements donc fait des
entraînements en ski c'est pas mon nez
ces secteurs et je viens justement à
l'internât comme ça c'est plus simple
est ce qu'on peut se reposer on est tous
avec notre entraîneur etc les puissantes
comme ça et le sport commence dès la
montée dans les chambres cinq étages à
gravir à pied la récompense est au bout
du couloir
trop bien on est contents de la voir
aussi contente
et puis forcément un petit peu
d'inquiétude pour des parents à laisser
leur leur fille comme ça en plus on a
une soeur jumelle donc on laisse les
deux là pour le coup donc forcément pour
les parents s'est retrouvé tout seul
venus de toute la région 200 élèves font
leur rentrée à l'internât c'est le quart
des effectifs du lycée bérard à mort et
c'est quand même plus confortable
d'arriver sur l'internât où on à la fois
du soutien scolaire qui va être
organisée la proximité du stade d'étude
qui va permettre de diminuer la fatigue
de ces jeunes athlètes qui déjà sont
beaucoup sur les routes pour les
compétitions donc oui c'est c'est un
choix qui est bien bien demandée par les
familles gage de réussite commodité ou
nécessité près de 6000 élèves suivront
leur scolarité en interne à cette année
dans l'académie de besançon